so in that sense we are partially lucky
and the reason i say partially is
because
we
on one hand our community is comprised
of developers which is amazing so if we
have power users you're hiring your
customers yes so we're just hiring our
users that's that's the most amazing
things that
a company can do
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet nimrod
kremer the ceo and co-founder of daily
dev
nimrod is a serial tech entrepreneur
based in israel he is the ceo and
co-founder of daily.dev a community
driven startup that's building the
homepage for every developer in the
world additionally nimrod sits on the
board of valega chain analytics he is
passionate about japanese culture coffee
table tennis and helping developers stay
up to date not necessarily in that order
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
thank you for having me thank you so
much for joining me here i love what
you're doing i am inspired by every
update that you do whether it's me going
every day to your homepage and seeing
the update or get or getting a little
bit from behind the scenes the company
that you're running daily dev out of a
real need that you've experienced
yourself that you your team has
experienced uh one of the most inspiring
things that you just mentioned to me
that you know one of the things that
you're that you're prioritizing is
having team members that are coming out
of the product and people that are using
the product and are loving the product
and i think you know in today's world
it's it's that's the right way to go so
anymore thank you so much for being here
tell me a little bit about yourself my
pleasure so i'm nimrod kramer i'm 30
years old uh originally from jerusalem
but now i'm living in italia and i'm the
co-founder and ceo of daily.dev
and our mission at daily.dev is to build
a homepage for every developer in the
world which is kind of an exciting uh
mission to go for it um and i'd love to
tell you more about it 15 years ago
people would have thought you were crazy
building a a consumer product for
developers who's the developer right
what why why are you doing this so you
know that's that's an amazing point
because one of the things that we've
been talking about lately in our team is
that if you look back a few years ago
developers were building software for
everyone but themselves right and that
came at the expense of what it means to
have a good developer experience what it
means to be a developer in 2020 2021 and
i think that now things are starting to
change and developers
are being put more in the center um
center of things center of organization
center of the decision-making processes
and it's about time that they will have
products that are designed for them okay
so let's take a step back who is a
developer what does it mean to be a
developer
share with me you know your persona of
what it means to be a developer
so obviously um
the definition can quite vary like it
depends on on like does a developer need
to be someone who writes code or can it
be someone um who is also working with
with no code or low code tools so there
is a wide definition there are also a
bunch of designers that are writing a
little bit css so the definition is
quite broad but i think that
or one thing one thing's for sure like
developers are not anymore those geeky
nerdy people with the eyeglasses sitting
in front of their computers all day like
you see a bunch of cool people that have
a say i'm not a developer myself
but you see a bunch of cool people that
um that know what they want that they're
um they have very strong opinions and
they are not afraid to express them
anymore right so you're so if you're
looking at developers building tools for
developers
the founding story of daily.dev take me
back to sort of the rationale of how you
even came up with this idea
so i think that's that's an amazing
story simply because daily that they've
started as a mistake yes so we we never
intended for it to be a business or to
be something big as it is today um it
started from a very small problem that
my co-founder ido had that he was what
she would call a developer news addict
or a junkie whatever word you want to
use and he was trying to consume a lot
of a lot of news but it was so
inefficient there's so much content out
there
there are so many low effort articles
and low quality articles that just takes
a lot of time and energy to to guess to
get this thing done and and in today's
world you cannot let yourself be out of
date like you got to be
um in the know
and so he built this thing for himself
he was the first user then the first 10
users were um other developers working
in the same r d department and the first
hundred users came from the from the
stores organically then one of them
apparently decided to launch it on
product and without even asking us
actually how we got like the first 1000
users actually from there it grew
organically which is kind of amazing and
right now we have more than 120 000
installs on the chrome store
unbelievable yeah you're the ceo of this
the leader of this ship and you're
watching it both grow organically
something that every entrepreneur just
wishes for themselves you know
everything that you're doing is guided
you know by this notion of product-led
growth and it's really true essence you
really are listening to developers and
then you're hiring the developers that
are using your platform
how do you know what to prioritize you
know in today's position where you're on
this fast growth pace
how do you know what to prioritize
so
obviously that's that's a huge question
um
but i think that that everything starts
from
being very thoughtful on what's
important and i'll give you just a quick
example so you see a bunch of products
on the market that they put the sign up
first just a small example right
but when you just start and if you're
really into product-led growth so you
gotta put your product first right so
if you just ask yourself a simple
question logical question like what
would you rather have a lot of users
that are using the app but are not
signed up or a lot of users who signed
up but are not using the app i think the
the answer is quite obvious what you
want to do
um
so it really comes down to asking
yourself the the tough questions and
putting yourself
in the developers shoes that's one point
the second point is that i think that
the entire paradigm of what it means to
do marketing
um is totally different when it comes to
developers so there's this term called
developer marketing and reality is that
it's nothing
but like it's not marketing at all so
when when you try to um
to explain some kind of other products
to different kinds of audiences usually
you would go with start with why explain
the benefits then how it works then what
you're providing like the kind of simon
sinek uh theme yeah when it comes to
developer they want to know
just what the f you're doing yeah they
want you to focus yeah cut the
just go
tell me what are you doing and how do
you do it and let me
have some way to prove it by myself
within 60 seconds i love it that's the
magic like that's the formula tell what
you're doing how you do it and let them
prove it by themselves that's like the
entire torah on one leg
now how does your day today look so what
is the day-to-day of the leadership you
know in this product like growth company
look like how much of it is you're
looking at the numbers versus talking to
the team versus trying out different
features doing a lot of a b testing that
i know you're doing sure so so
definitely at this stage and even
earlier we're a data driven uh company
that this is like a big buzzword but
very little
amount of people know what what it
exactly means
so um
when you start building your product and
it gains scale so it's very hard to
decide what to do next like we have a
huge community that they're constantly
asking for features they constantly ask
for
new stuff to build and
the only way to know if something works
is to measure it and
once you adopt a decision-making
framework that is based on data it makes
things so much easier because
opinions doesn't matter anymore just hey
you think this feature is good let's put
it out there let's a b test it then
let's look at the result did it improve
sure let's apply it on the entire user
base it didn't work it didn't improve
anything let's just bury this thing down
and
and it really helps to drive the
organization forward in
extremely fast pace the difficulties to
adopt the framework and and to really
and to actually be efficient with it and
and you're not a traditional company
that is sitting
you know in serona
or in san francisco with a beautiful
office beautiful landscape doing you
know the thursday afternoon happy hours
are you definitely not so we're a fully
remote or even remote first team i would
say like everybody's working from home
we have employees in five different
geographies
what does that mean remote first for you
remote first means that um
you don't even consider having an office
so it means that
by design
you are crafting the the com the
organization of the company in a way
that you can work with anyone anywhere
at any time zone in a non-linear
asynchronous manner that's a lot of big
words here but basically what it means
is that you need to create
culture and you need to create work
processes where people are as
independent as possible and they can
deliver without any dependency at all
so this is it right now you're building
the culture right now you're building
the team you're growing the team what
what are you facing what is it like
building a remote first team you're
going to be now seven people right i
can't imagine if we if we were to have
this interview this time next quarter or
you'll be but you know how do you
prioritize you know building the right
things here within the team
so uh within the team we're trying to
adopt a lean approach so we're just
trying to shift something and then if
there's
anything gets stuck in the work process
we stop for a second we think about it
we find you in our work processes and
then we move ahead otherwise things will
get broken really really fast um this is
one aspect of it the other aspect is the
hiring which
i think that the most common issue if
you ask any tech ceo especially in
israel now is hiring especially hiring
technical talent that's just
a mess getting the applicants is a mess
it's not just finding the right
applicants it's how do you get them to
actually apply and to want to come to
work for you yeah so so in that sense we
are partially lucky uh and the reason i
say partially is because
we
on one hand our community is comprised
of developers which is amazing so if we
have power users you're hiring your
customers yes so we're just hiring our
users that's that's the most amazing
things that uh yeah that a company can
do because people come with a very
strong conviction on
why this product exists where it should
be in the future and they want to be
part of it because they are using it
themselves so that's that's a great
thing about it the second great thing
about it is that you get to tap into
global
pool of talent
so all of a sudden you don't have to
hire people that are based locally just
here in israel there are obviously
amazing people and really talented
people here but for a small company no
matter how much venture funding you have
it's really hard to hire
so um
just having the option
to go fully remote just having the
option to hire someone in the
netherlands in
the philippines and whatever you want
is a huge advantage nowadays i think and
that would be a very important factor in
our growth
where are you in all this
nimrod
i'm in all of this i'm just i'm just an
enabler so my job is to make sure that
everyone have enough time enough
resources and enough motivation to do
their job this is where i'm in the
company um
and the second thing that i'm in charge
of is talking to the community which
started as something doable like when
you just have several hundreds or
several thousands of users that's easy
like you can communicate with a lot of
them but right now it became it become
it becomes like a huge challenge and
we're constantly trying to adopt ways to
uh collect feedback and scale so
i can talk entirely about it but this is
like one of the great things we do if
you're looking at the developers as a
community
and you're enriching them with
information you're giving them a
community you're giving them space
what are what are some non-trivial
things that you've learned about the
developers community and this new
species that have emerged now to become
very very popular in the world
no longer the geeks with the eyeglasses
but just traditional people that are
that are working as developers what have
you learned about this community that
you didn't necessarily know a year or
two years ago
so
that's that's a little bit difficult
question because like i've been working
with developers for a lot of times so a
lot of the myths around it were already
busted in in my case but
what i'm i'm i'm really happy to see is
that developers are
um
becoming more of
business people and more they're more
centric in terms of like the
decision-making processes in the
organization
and
and they're giving a lot of autonomy
right with the bottom-up approaches yeah
and like for instance uh a couple weeks
ago i participated in
in a conference in real life all right
so that's changed and i was quite
surprised to see a lot of developers
asking business questions like i would
expect them to ask about what's your
tech stack like how do you build that
how do you do this or do that but they
ask how do you make money actually like
what's a business model what's the
growth plan and that that was
shocking for me you know like i would
never expect developers to ask those
kind of those kind of questions and i
think that's that's a blessed change
um
and i think we're going to see more and
more of that i love it what do you enjoy
most about this journey as an
entrepreneur
if you're looking at you know your
day-to-day you know your personal life
professional life know what gives you
the most joy and inspiration
so i'm that i'm that kind of
entrepreneur who tries to optimize for
happiness that's what does that mean
that's that's
i'm gonna share my philosophy in a
second here um but basically it means to
work on something that i love with
people that i love on a mission that i
love this is like the
sounds like a dream come true yeah for
me definitely like i work with with
co-founders and team members that i
really deeply appreciate and i truly
believe that they are smarter than i am
and they are giving more value than than
i can give so that's just a great place
to be and i i always learn i just see
what they do i get inspired and and i
just it drives me forward
um
but in terms of happiness i think it's
all about um
not trying to chase perfection you know
there's something about
the world today where people always say
when i get to this point i'm going to be
happy when i achieve this perfect thing
i'm going to be happy and the thing
about perfection is that once you
achieve it it's not perfect anymore
so people who are chasing the next thing
or chasing perfection they will be
always frustrated in my opinion
and so as far as i'm concerned i'm
trying to leave every moment trying to
be
really mindful of what i do and
appreciate like every second even this
interview everything i love i i can feel
both here and the previous conversations
that we've had you're always very in in
the moment
uh you're not floating somewhere looking
for the next thing but you're living
right here right now and and i think
that it also shows in and how
intentional the products that you're
building are and how they there's a lot
of intentionality behind the different
features that you're doing because there
are the features of here and now not the
features of of later on
there's a lot of creativity in the work
that you're doing right and you have to
get a lot of inspiration for for what
features to build and how do you look at
the right matrix and how do you get the
right people on your team where do you
derive your inspiration from
um that's a great question i think that
that my inspiration comes from
all sorts of things that are not related
to tech at all
so really yeah i'm really passionate
about a lot of stuff like i'm i'm
i really love sound engineering for
instance so it's some kind of tech but
when i say sound engineering i mean more
recording and studio recording and
mixing and editing stuff
and i get a lot of inspiration from the
way problems are solved in this domain
and i try to apply it into our domain
that's just one example another example
is
is in sports or in different books that
i read on all sorts of of topics so this
kind of cross
cross discipline do you have time to
just leisurely read and uh i make time
you make time that's part of the
intentionality of the here and now yeah
exactly
five years in the future
right now organic you have more than a
hundred thousand of active users that
are that truly are engaged and they love
your product
you went on product hunt without wanting
to be on product hunt where do you see
daily.dev as a community as a product
whatever it may be what is the impact
that it's going to have in five years
that's that's an amazing question i
think the um
being in a position where
you're a developer tool but not in a
sense that you're helping developers
write better software faster software
more efficient software but you're
helping developers
um have a home as a persona this is
something that's currently not really
existent it's it's quite like scattered
across all many many platforms so just
having that one place
can
unleash so much creativity can unleash
so many things that developers can do
together so um i think that the future
for daily.devs relies in
live story in collaboration and bringing
developers together and
taking developers with shared interest
to solve massive problems together and
to inspire one another and just to to be
better versions of themselves and at the
end of the day it's going to impact
everyone so
it's a cliche but now every company is a
software company right even every
company my grandma had to to make an
appointment in in the
in one of the clinics and she has to use
an app someone built that app so if i
can touch like so many developers as
daily.dev and to help them become 0.1
better i really think that we're going
to contribute um
to a better world i love it and you
might have to say that i i love the
product i love the vision i love the way
that you're approaching it
and a lot of people like to talk about
product like growth and data-driven
decisions and
and i think for me it's rare to meet
somebody who's actually so intentional
about it and is not using it as a
buzzword or as a catchphrase but it's
just saying this is what's happening and
at the end you're building a product for
developers and i think that the the
sentence that resonates with me the most
saying like listen our customers all
they want is for us to cut the
and they want to prove within 60 seconds
that it's useful for them and if you're
showing that they're coming back after
those 60 seconds that's all because of
the product it's not because of
marketing it's not because of the
business model it's because you've built
a great product and i think that's the
highest conviction that anybody can get
to so really congratulations on the
whole progress until now and i can't
wait to see what's happening with
daily.dev and best of luck thanks man i
really appreciate it